four hundred thousand that's the number
of subscribers netflix lost in us and
canada last quarter the first time it
has lost subscribers in those markets
since early 2019.
netflix is a business that is driven by
one and one thing only subscriber growth
to maintain its position as the market
leader keep investors happy and have a
luxury of spending eye-popping amounts
of money that number needs to trend
upwards continually and preferably as
fast as possible netflix's current
number of ping subscribers worldwide is
200 million while this number is
impressive the loss of 400 000
subscribers in the us and canada shows
that the streaming giant is struggling
to maintain its meteoric growth amidst a
growing competition the shuttering
growth wasn't entirely unexpected the
company enjoyed a flood of new
subscribers in early 2020 around 16
million as the shelter at home orders
were put in place as restrictions have
loosened some of those new subscribers
would have churned causing the slowdown
but there are other troubling signs for
the big streamer competition continues
to eat into netflix share one of its
rivals hbo max has gained nearly 3
million subscribers in the last quarter
another important competitor disney plus
continue to grow at a rapid pace as well
the number of disney plus subscribers
has already surpassed 100 million
subscribers worldwide on top of that
google video streaming site youtube has
become an important player in the
connected tv space competing for the
viewers time according to recent data
more than 120 million people watch
youtube on a connected or smart tv
device monthly up from 100 million a
year ago however what is even more
worrying for netflix is that for all of
its spending the streamer has produced
very few big hits in the last year
in 2021 less than five percent of
netflix most watched programs were
produced in-house as a result customers
have been switching to hbo max and
disney plus who continue to produce high
quality content and blockbuster releases
so it comes as no surprise that netflix
is looking for new growth markets the
company has recently announced that it
might be expanding to gaming
specifically mobile gaming netflix has
been long aware that it competes with
the gaming industry for time and
attention with reid hastings ceo of
netflix one saying we compete with and
lose to fortnite more than hbo it's
another case of if you can't compete
with them join them new rumors have
recently surfaced then the company is
looking to partner with playstation
though there are no details yet on when
what or how netflix has confirmed that
games will be included in subscriptions
fees at no extra cost no one knows how
this move will affect netflix business
prospects in the years to come at least
it shows the company is ready to explore
new formats to increase time spent on
the platform whether it will improve the
company's bottom line remains to be seen
but video games will definitely attract
new customers especially the younger
market captivated by games like fortnite
and minecraft this will allow netflix to
offer something none of its direct
competitors provide